let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
good afternoon everybody welcome to
let's talk the tony michaels podcast
lot of [ __ ] going on the american rescue
plan was passed
looks like it'll make its way to
president biden's desk
on friday a lot of [ __ ] went on this
last week too
[Music]
we had a uh an interview
[Music]
take place miss oprah winfrey
exposed the royal family
of course you know we all knew they were
racist but
you know they exposed it who would have
guessed
who would have guessed and then we have
the continuation of this
cancel culture [ __ ] about people
whining about
you know cancel culture as if it anyone
gives a [ __ ] or it even [ __ ] matters
so but uh we're gonna have a good show
today i
thank you for joining us you see my new
hats the [ __ ] hats
if you guys want some [ __ ] hats go to
thetonymichaels.com
at the very top there's a link that'll
get you to the hats
if you'd like one there's gray and black
and we're gonna have some trucker hats
here soon
but these are these are flex fit i'm i'm
trying to model these things here see oh
i'm a very nice hat
let's let's bring let's bring salmon to
join us here
hey sam how are you hi guys what's up
how do you like the [ __ ] hats do you
like the new [ __ ] hats i always like
the [ __ ] hats
big man look at there look at nice nice
it's a nice fitted flex fit hat and they
they come in
gray and black so if you like
something like that yeah well you know
you know i'm thinking about these
trucker hats we might do like
we might do like red or or red white and
blue
i might i definitely am going to do gold
black and gold
for mu yeah we do black and gold kind of
on here
yep that's kind of our color color
scheme here so we'll try to maybe just
put a flag on it oh yeah hey that's a
good idea red white and blue
that way we can be patriotic maybe we'll
maybe we'll do that in july we'll
release one of those
for everyone to buy [ __ ] um it's kind of
in that
kind of backwards though like i'm so
patriotic [ __ ] them
i don't know but you know i mean
americans it works
they were based on being rebellious in
the beginning so
might as well just keep it going
right right that's like the american
[ __ ] way [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them [ __ ] those brits [ __ ] them we
want our independence
[ __ ] them speaking of brits
speaking of brits and britain and the uk
did you get a chance to watch the
the great interview with prince harry
and meg meghan markle
did you watch us i haven't got to watch
it yet uh but i've heard okay
i've heard some things you've heard some
things you've heard some things so what
do you
so i guess my question is because um i
think
meghan markle is like drop dead gorgeous
she is a beautiful beautiful woman
yes do you think harry is attractive
he's a redhead he's the cuter one of the
brothers
for sure okay so so like if you if you
flip the coin for one of the two
he's the one you'd want to flip for he's
the one i would hope for
okay but he's he's a redhead so so
to it you know you're a redhead he's a
redhead
you know do redheads attractor edits i
don't know this kind of stuff i really
do
i i personally don't go for redheads
i'm a big brunette fan oh okay well you
know well you know
that that happens that happens you know
when we have uh
when you know we have you know you know
you know we have we have preferences
so this so this interview what i took
from this interview was a couple
different things
number one they like really they really
dogged on oprah
for not you know getting real deep
inside their lives or whatever
number one oprah winfrey is oprah
winfrey
you're not gonna [ __ ] with oprah winfrey
yeah i mean she does she is
she's gonna do what the [ __ ] she wants
she doesn't give a [ __ ]
she's oprah for crying out loud and
what's what's crazy is to me is
like oprah's more famous than these two
for sure yes way more famous i mean yeah
he's a prince but
she's a queen she's oprah for crying
yeah she is she was the queen of daytime
talk for
two decades i mean no one touched her
until she retired and then ellen kind of
took over that that spot right
yep so i mean she was the daytime queen
oprah is the talk show queen
and how however anyone said well how she
she's not a good interviewer i'm like
what the [ __ ] she interviewed people for
for
30 years get the hell out of here yeah
that was her job right she's
she actually is really good at it she
actually what i what i liked because i
watched the entire interview
i was only going to watch clips of it
but you know everyone was so up in arms
about this goddamn thing
that i decided just to watch the whole
interview front to back just watch the
whole [ __ ] thing that way i could say
hey i watched it and here's what i think
about it [ __ ]
so the thing that the thing that i
thought she did really well is
like she turned what what most people
the royals
she turned their they she turned them
into humans
whereas you know most these people that
do like a
like an interview they're kind of like
cyborgs almost
you know they're not even you know don't
even seem like they're
you know real people but she turned them
into real people so
but uh but yeah i'll talk about that
here in a second
okay i'll talk about you know all the
good good good goody stuff
here in a second did you see my tweet
since you're a royals fan
did you see my tweet i i tweeted out uh
what's the score in the royals game
because you know the royals because the
royals
yeah yeah right right the royals
the royals and oprah and the score
and who was going to win who was going
to lose right yeah you see what i did
there you see what i did
well you know all right dude thanks for
joining us
thanks for joining us see you sami
all right so let's talk about this
interview because i think it's i think
it's
as important as nothing really um i mean
it's basically oprah winfrey
interviewing famous people
about their little riff with their
family and
uh the royals number one in america we
it's
really confusing the thing the thing
that i think i got the most out of this
interview is that
the weird ass [ __ ] that they call like
the institution in the firm
that was the weirdest [ __ ] thing
about the interview honestly that that
that they actually refer to the people
who kind of control the royals and the
queen
as the firm and the institution it's
like it's some kind of [ __ ] movie now
i know i don't um
indulge in watching uh the crown or
really any of these uh these shows about
royalty and the king my wife has watched
several of these series before fictional
and
you know they did non-fictional i guess
if you want to call them that they try
to base it on real life
and then they had a a fictional one she
watched for a while i think it was
actually called the royals
and i didn't actually participate in
watching that piece of
[ __ ] but because i'm really not
interested in a monarchy
not at all uh frankly uh monarchies
suck that's why we left it so many years
ago and that's really why
in the uk the only thing keeping the
monarchy alive is
somehow the hard-on of the peoples that
they have about the monarchy
i mean i i think that's the thing that
they exposed the most that the monarchy
is nothing but a tabloid
it's nothing but entertainment that's
all it is
i mean it's basically their couple
hundred years of kardashians over there
that's all it is just a big [ __ ]
piece of entertainment real [ __ ]
expensive entertainment but a piece of
entertainment
but a couple of things that i got out of
the interview um from
harry and meghan markle themselves is
number one
number one is that
the thing about the the archie's skin
color
so that was the one thing that i thought
was inconsistent with the two-story
the way that they presented it because
when oprah was asking meghan markle
about uh basically the racist component
of the royal family and she had brought
up that
they'd said that archie they were
questioning archie's skin color
she made it seem as if that happened
during her pregnancy
and then when harry was asked about it
it seemed like he said that happened
before they got married so that was the
only inconsistency in it but does it
matter
does it matter when the people of the
royal family were
asking about the baby skin color or what
skin color it would be or the tone of
its skin
does it really [ __ ] matter of course
it doesn't matter it's [ __ ] racist no
matter which
when they said it or why they said it or
what context they set it in
but that's the only way that they really
expose themselves in the interview at
least the portions that they aired
that seemed to kind of contradict itself
that was it
that was it and to to say that these two
people are [ __ ] lying
it's just a bunch of [ __ ] right-wing
fascist trash
that's all that is to to accuse them
of the ones that were left out you know
they they
they hurt the royal family they're the
ones who did all the damage
me a [ __ ] break these people left
the life of of whatever luxury they
wanted now
you know you had to be imprisoned inside
this institution or the firm
which is a really weird [ __ ]
component of this thing
uh and i guess because i really don't
pay attention to monarchies or care
less about what the monarchy is doing or
isn't doing
i i didn't really know that that
component of it
uh but apparently they have a really
strong hold on
the queen and the princes and the whole
[ __ ]
[ __ ] and kabuto of them because it's
kind of like the tabloids
control the monarchy of the monarchy
kind of control the tabloids
to be relevant to stay relevant so that
they can
stay a monarchy and be the
uk's entertainment i guess because
that's really what it seems like to me i
don't know
if it seems like that to anyone else but
to accuse these two a [ __ ] lion
because they're
somehow they're liberals which i don't
even understand
what makes them so liberal i mean what
makes them so liberal just
just because they're not bigots means
they're not liberals what does that say
about the right wing and conservatives
in this country because that's really
the thing that i paid attention to was a
[ __ ] reaction
in this country from the right wingers
because no one no one i mean of course
there was the reaction
of of the racist component of it which i
don't think anyone was really surprised
about the racist component of of the
interview where they were talking about
uh the the baby's skin color
and the tone of his skin and how dark
his skin would be or how dark their
children's skin would be i don't think
anyone was surprised that that happened
i think the surprising part was they
actually set it in front of a camera
like they came out and said yes this
happened like they admitted it happened
that was kind of like holy [ __ ]
you know they're kind of they're telling
on their family and i mean they didn't
say who it was
they didn't say who said it and they
wouldn't say who said it i'm not going
to say that i'm not going to say that
but i mean let's be clear from from the
the the way that the interview played
out it really seemed like
it came from his father but you know
that's that's my
assumption and what what the [ __ ] is my
assumption worth
really what the hell is that worth
not a goddamn nickel i i bet i couldn't
even get into buckingham palace with
with the amount of money that uh my
opinion is worth for [ __ ] sure
so but but i mean i think that was the
really the reaction
that this country went what the hell the
right-wing media charlie kirk
ben shapiro um
fox news they all went to the defense of
the monarchy
these are the same [ __ ] that
that yell and scream all day long
how elitist in this country are trying
to cancel them which we're going to talk
about cancel culture today this [ __ ]
oh the elites in this country they think
they're so much smarter they go to
colleges and blah blah blah blah blah
lead elite elite coastal elites telling
us what to do and how to think blah blah
blah
and then the moment the moment
that these [ __ ] [ __ ] can
can defend the
non-elites the people who left the elite
club
who were kicked out of the elite club
publicly
they defend the elites they defend the
the oldest [ __ ] clan of elites in the
entire world
the british monarchy that's straight
where they went
was yeah the monarchy ah meghan markle
she's a [ __ ]
she she she trying to take down the
monarchy
she's trying to take them she's trying
to cancel them so let's
cancel harry and megan this is this is
the cancel culture [ __ ]
and then and then of course they went on
and on and on about oprah
because they know they know oprah's you
know she's some kind of
part of the the hollywood cabal that's
you know
queueing on says it's sucking the blood
out of children
have superpowers give me a [ __ ] break
this is all nonsense so ben shapiro and
charlie kirk
come to the defense of the oldest
[ __ ] elites a clan of elites in the
entire world
the white pasty ass elites in the entire
world
and they think that's a good look give
me a [ __ ] break
if they if they really wanted to spin
this into the to the right wing
they could have spun it into the oh the
monarchy tried to cancel
harry and megan how dare they but no
that's not the way they went
and then the very next morning we seen
pierce morgan who apparently has some
kind
of weird-ass fetish about uh meghan
markle
because apparently the story goes that
he introduced
her and harry or something and and she
ghosted him after he introduced so he's
butt hurt or some [ __ ] [ __ ] pierce
morgan
pierce ted cruz pierce morgans
[ __ ] him who the hell likes pierce
morgan not a goddamn i mean maybe ted
cruz
and maybe the only reason why ted cruz
likes piers morgan is because
he's the only one hated more in this
world than pierce morgan
tech cruises jesus christ
but he he goes on and on and on in this
diatribe
and just it's just a sexist
racist diatribe of course coming from
pierce morgan's garbage hole
and then the very next morning one of
the hosts or the weatherman or whoever
it is on
a good morning britain
uh challenges him on it and he gets butt
hurt and he's a [ __ ] crybaby
[ __ ] [ __ ] gets up and walks off the
set
acts like he's been he's been he's been
oh you're gonna make fun of me you're
gonna come after me
you're you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna attack me well you were attacking
her you
you worthless piece of [ __ ]
so you can dish it out but you can't
take it come on
and he's always entered himself
personally into her story and their
story anyways
on several different talk shows several
different times he's always entering
himself
into the story by claim that he
introduced him and she
ghosted him the [ __ ] out of here so he
basically cancels himself
which is which is fantastic i think it's
great that he cancels himself
uh off off good morning britain so
but you know the interview
if i had to recommend watching the
interview um
if you have an hour or an hour and a
half whatever long it was
uh that you can spare you might watch it
but if you
don't have that kind of time it's it's
probably not worth your time as far as
uh knowing about the monarchy and
knowing that the monarchy
um that their their they're racist
of course they are they're pasty white
monarchy that
that hinge on the the supremacy of their
bloodline
that's the point is supremacy and it is
not surprising
that ben shapiro charlie kirk pierce
morgan
sean hannity fox news and all these
[ __ ] right-wing
[ __ ] in this country came to the
defense
of the white supremacist british
monarchy
a [ __ ] break it's not that surprising
and speaking
speaking of these ass wipes shapiro
and kirk and hannity and fox news
i want to talk about this cancel culture
this cancer culture stuff
first i think i'm gonna play a tick tock
we're doing a new thing here on
on the videos so you gotta give me a
minute here i'm gonna i'm gonna
show you i'm gonna show you uh a tick
tock that i did about the
the royal family here real quick and
then we'll we'll
come let's see gonna work it's gonna
work
bear with me here
trying oh there we go yeah there it is
okay
so that was my that was my little video
on
uh on uh on the royals that i did for
the tick tock
um and then i i did one on on pierce
pearson ted cruz but we'll leave that
one alone but
i want to get back to this this the
cancer culture thing
because really uh it's
it's crazy about
this dr seuss and now
now the muppets and dumbo
and the mr potato head and they keep
going on and on and
on and there was a great great great
video
of of tim ryan um
on the the floor of the house and i
think it was today or yesterday
when they were debating the american
relief package which we are going to get
into here in a little bit
about what that american relief package
means and how that is important for
americans and it's probably
one of the more important things that
that are going on right now
than this cancel culture [ __ ] in this
interview with the royals thing
uh prince harry and meghan markle i
don't
know is he a prince anymore i don't know
i know that the kid isn't a prince which
i'm gonna call him prince archie i don't
give a [ __ ]
what the monarchy says that's what i'm
going to call him [ __ ] him
prince archie but anyways
the cancer culture thing because that's
what they want to do they want to cancel
prince archie then cancel culture
[ __ ]
and want to cancel archie you know
that's that's how they play this game
because they don't understand they don't
get they don't get the difference
between cancer culture and boycotting
and
and and a publisher not deciding not to
publish their material that they
own they don't understand what the [ __ ]
the difference is
they don't [ __ ] get it they do not
get it and these
[ __ ] right wingers are the ones who
[ __ ] created cancer culture in the
first place
they started all this [ __ ] they
started all this stuff
back in the 70s and the 80s with jerry
falwell
and liberty university and the american
family association
they started all this this boycott
cancer culture [ __ ] they invented it
they invented it they would go after
publishers who would publish books
they'd burn
books they'd burn uh music
they would ban music they would boycott
this they would boycott that
and they'd get all their churches and
their their you know
their their in their christian
infrastructure the evangelical
infrastructure to cancel all this stuff
cancel well listen dr
seuss the [ __ ] company that's the
estate of
dr seuss who owns the [ __ ]
books gets to decide whether those books
are [ __ ] printed or not
that's how it works that's called
[ __ ] capitalism
they own the product they get the side
rather they package it and distribute it
or not
that's how it [ __ ] works if chevrolet
decides not to make a [ __ ] silverado
anymore
they don't have to make a silverado
anymore they don't
the consumer doesn't get to say oh
chevrolet
they they aren't making they aren't
making the chevette
anymore they canceled the chevette
are you [ __ ] serious how egregious
how dare they strip us the right of of
of a car that's a piece of [ __ ] how dare
they that's
cancelled culture and it's gonna destroy
our country shut the [ __ ] up
these are the same dumb [ __ ]
that went on and on and on and on about
how harry potter was satanic
and the boycott harry potter and not
watch the movies not read the books
same [ __ ] same [ __ ]
these are the same [ __ ] that
wanted that that want a [ __ ] boycott
abc and disney
because they had gays oh
there was there was gay people in their
shows and then their material
what i mean this this last
the the frozen one of the characters in
frozen is
assumed to be gay and they want to
cancel that movie they want to boycott
it how dare they
go against christian christian values
that they this is what they do
this is what they do they did it to dr
seuss with the lorax the lorax the movie
i talked about it on
the last [ __ ] podcast and here we are
a week later still talking about this
[ __ ] garbage
because these [ __ ] morons will not
[ __ ] quit
now the best news about the dr seuss
the the boycotting of dr seuss's is
michael beschloss
if you don't know who michael beschloss
is he's uh he's a presidential historian
and he posted um a picture
of a political cartoon this morning the
atlantic ran an article about dr
seuss and the political cartoons that he
actually drew
uh during the second world war and he
actually drew political cartoons that
looked like dr seuss cartoons
that were anti-fascist antifa
doctor dr seuss was antifa
oh my god dr seuss was antifa
what are we gonna do
[ __ ] boneheads so he comes out with
these political cartoons
that are anti-hitler obviously and the
best part about one of these cartoons
and i'll share it here let me let me get
it up here
uh the best part about one of these
cartoons
is that the sweater if you see it here
see if i got it here let's see if that
i think that's working oh yeah there it
is okay okay the sweater here let me
make it big
the sweater here says america first on
it
and the book that the mom the fascist
mom is reading to the
terrified children is called adolf the
wolf
adolf being you know the adolf that is
famous for being a wolf and it says
and the wolf chewed up the children and
spit out their bones
but those were foreign children and it
really didn't matter yeah there's you
some for some dr
seuss here let me let me let me get it
down here like that there you now you
can see
you can see the words there that's the
picture it's on i retweeted it a couple
times
i actually retweeted it out that uh don
jr junior
and tucker carlson asked don jr if this
was his america's first
sweater and that's really the thing that
i took from this picture the most
is these knuckle draggers didn't even
notice the america first thing on the
sweater
and she's in support of adolf that's the
point of the cartoon
people
he was he was doing antifa
anti-fascist political cartoons
dr seuss he's part of antiva
oh oh my god
so i'm wondering i'm wondering how long
it's going to take fox news oan newsmax
all these [ __ ] outlets out there
ben shapiro charlie kirk tucker carlson
sean hannity i wonder how long it's
going to take him to figure out
that dr seuss was antifa antifa
anti-fascist i wonder how long it's
going to take them to cancel dr seuss
all of a sudden
we can't read green eggs and ham anymore
because it was written by antifa
it was written by antifa that green eggs
and ham
it was written by antifa
because he was dr seuss was anti-fascist
he was antifa
eat your [ __ ] heart out you canceled
culture heroes
cancel culture that [ __ ] so i wonder how
long it's going to take them
to reverse course on this dr seuss thing
and
try to scrub kevin mccarthy can try to
scrub the entire internet of
his dumb ass trying to read green eggs
and ham to
the internet which that was that was
nice that was nice
so they started cancel culture with
these boycotts and stuff
and they continue to to go on and on and
on about cancel culture
and then we have don jr complaining
about the muppets
because disney has a has a uh
a disclaimer before the muppets
which is no different than like a tv
rating
that we have now the disclaimer
so what it's still on there you still
watch it it's not
canceled you dumb [ __ ] so
so i wonder when i wonder
so don jr
he wants to cancel andrew cuomo's book
he wants to cancel a book
because you know cancel culture because
it's all right if they do it it's not
all right if everyone else does it's
okay if they do it
anyone tired of this [ __ ] cancel
culture [ __ ] yet
so having spoken about cancel culture
and the
the tim ryan video tim ryan actually
um going on the floor i'm going to see
if i can find that here real quick
while i'm talking about it tim ryan
going on the floor of the house
and telling you some [ __ ] how it is
um about how they're basically you
knuckle draggers you're
you're totally totally avoiding the
american people and what the american
people need
but you're concentrated on on [ __ ] dr
seuss
i can't find it we'll we'll skip around
around here
but uh he basically says you know stop
stop worrying about dr seuss and cancel
culture and worry about the american
people
and that's basically what happened the
last week with this coronavirus package
is the democrats are actually working
hard
to try to get the american people not
only relief from the last 12 months of
economic ruin but also get them
uh pump this vaccine out get it into
people's arms as fast as we possibly can
and also there was a lot of other stuff
in this package you know they they want
to say oh well
only this amount of it was for
coronavirus
well i mean what do you mean that amount
was for coronavirus what the hell though
in the last year hasn't anything had to
do with but coronavirus
because the last former guy [ __ ] this
whole thing up
that's why we're in the situation that
we're in anyways
i mean really it it's been proven now
that
joe biden is going to damn near
vaccinate
uh 40 to 50 percent of the population
within 90 days
and donald trump had almost 60 days to
do that and he didn't
he didn't get even close not even close
because he didn't give a [ __ ] he was too
concerned about how he's going to
overthrow the government
and to make sure that we have the people
that are still left on unemployment
from coronavirus and now they lowered it
from 400 to 300 but they're still going
to get relief
we get americans who who have no fault
of their own got smacked in the face
this last year
over this coronavirus they're going to
get some financial help and these
stimulus
this the these stimulus checks uh the
majority of americans
we also we also are going to see this
child credit thing
which i'll talk about here in a second
which is very interesting
um and
there was it's funny because there was
supposed to be bipartisan support from
mitt romney but
i didn't actually get vote on that way
because we got no bipartisan support
which [ __ ] them who gives a [ __ ]
obviously we can run the government
without these son of a [ __ ] and we
should
we totally should totally run the
government without these idiots
we need to get rid of that filibuster
and there's been some movement on that
which we we can talk about too
actually you know what let's go ahead
and play a tick tock let's do that let's
play a tick tock here on the filibuster
that i had
[ __ ] them let's show them what i think
about the filibuster
okay let's see here where's that phil
there it is filibuster this
and that is exactly how i feel about the
filibuster
is the hell of them tell them let's get
rid of this filibuster now
it seems like the movement on the
filibuster is this
uh joe manchin who kind of holds the
cards here for the filibuster
uh it looks like we're having technical
difficulties with some of these videos
so we're not gonna we're not gonna do it
that way next time we'll go back to the
way we're doing it's people are saying
they're not hearing the videos so uh
we'll go back to the way that we used to
do it that that didn't work we
experimented this time
but anyways the filibuster uh joe
manchin
kind of holds the keys to the filibuster
here and the reason why
is because he's kind of the deciding
boat right
to end this [ __ ] or not and he doesn't
want to end it
which you know fine handicapped the [ __ ]
out of it
and what what apparently his idea is to
have a standing filibuster go back to a
standing filibuster
and then to where they actually have to
have fun members on the floor to
filibuster they have to do a real
[ __ ] filibuster not just
not this [ __ ] stuff not this
[ __ ] stuff
they have to do a real real filibuster
they have to stand there 41 members on
the floor and hold the floor for a
filibuster
which that's the way they should do it
that's the way they should have to do it
and and it appears that way that that's
the way joe manson is going to take this
thing
which uh ultimately could get us uh to
the minimum wage and could get us the
john lewis voting rights act
which those those those two things
are super important um i think also
either repairing the aaca permanently or
coming up with some sort of fix for
universal health care coverage
uh whether it be public option or
something else i think is important too
and i think doing the standing
filibuster will actually make these
republicans do work and i think they
will not do that
if they have to stand there and talk for
days and days and weeks on end and have
41 members in the senate they're not
going to do that
they don't care enough about anything to
do that kind of [ __ ] they don't give a
[ __ ] about anything
besides raising money that's very
evident in
what donald trump's statement there was
the other day oh don't give the rnc
money give me money
and i i think i think this is
this is a beautiful way for donald trump
really to [ __ ] eat his own [ __ ]
sandwich here
because what happens when the rnc
outrages his ass oh my god that's gonna
be fantastic
to watch the rnc outrage donald trump
and to see how
[ __ ] irrelevant he is which speaking
of irrelevancy
there's been chatter that he's gonna get
his twitter account back
which [ __ ] i i'm excited about that too
that's fantastic
that would be great for him to get his
twitter account back for everyone to see
how irrelevant this dumb [ __ ] actually
is
that would be great and fantastic
so but but but uh anyways back to the
relief package
um they they got it passed in the senate
they had to take the 15 minimum wage out
of
the the bill bernie's forced a vote
so we watched all republicans and eight
democrats
uh vote against it which uh you know
hell that's a whole another
goddamn podcast in and of itself in the
eight democrats that actually
voted against this thing but bernie
sanders got them on the record and that
is the most important thing here
because there is 20 republican seats
that are going to be available
in the next uh midterm and that's going
to be important and
there's already been five republicans
that have announced their retirement
looks like ron johnson's going to
bite the bullet too and retire because i
i think he's he knows he's he's not he's
not going to have a [ __ ] chance in hell
because he's
attached himself to trump too much and
uh not only is trump irrelevant but he's
unpopular
and if anyone wonders uh why these
senators are retiring like roy blunt
here in missouri if they're wondering
why they're retiring
it's because of what they saw in georgia
that's why because trump
not only did not help them
did not help the republicans in georgia
he actually actually got them the loss
he actively made them lose in georgia
those two races if you looked at the
vote and looked the vote count from the
actual november third election
those republicans should have
one-handedly and between november 3rd
and january 5th the democrats were able
to
take those seats back now thanks to the
hard work to stacey abrams and all the
people who went out and voted
in georgia but donald trump did not help
those republicans
at all at all and i think that's the
calculus that some of these republican
senators are doing
and they're trying to figure out okay
well if if if
that's not going to help if that's not
going to make us win i'm definitely not
going to have
a legacy ruining uh loss here because
roy blunt in missouri
he knows he knows he's going to have
eric greitens or billy long
running against him in a primary he's
going to get primaried
he's for sure going to get primaried and
for a sitting united states senator
republican
part of the establishment i mean jesus
christ he's a third leader in the hat
and the senate
third line he's part of leadership and
to lose to a disgraced
governor who allegedly duct taped a
woman to a
a treadmill and raped her and he had to
resign as a result
of not only that but possible financial
crimes
by by illegally using donations that he
took from a veterans group that he ran
allegedly of course he doesn't want to
lose to that
of course he doesn't want to lose it
would ruin his
complete entire legacy
so roy blunty does the easy thing
you know punts on it and he retires
before it can even get started
and the reason why he retires before he
can even get started is because he
doesn't want to watch these republicans
run in on this on this race
and then look like he's walking away
because eric greitens billy long or
whoever
whoever is going to be the the
runners-up for this thing which
i would love and i'm i'm here in
missouri and i would love to watch
that fat slob billy long
and that dumb [ __ ] eric greitens go at
it in a primary
nothing would please me more get the
trumpiest of the trumps of the trump
trumps
to really prove to this state that yep
that's what the republican party is and
what it's going to be
now a lot of people have asked a
question who's going to be the
democratic nominee claire mccaskill said
no
no no no you're not going to catch me in
a race
now she said ever but she said you're
not going to catch me in this in a race
and some people are assuming that we
could look and uh back and see that jay
nixon the former democratic governor who
was a two-term democratic governor
before eric greitens won could run which
i think is a complete possibility but
we'll see we'll see what
we'll see what shakes out over the next
18 months
as we uh see who enters the race and see
how the primary would play out
but the fact that the fact remains that
roy blunt
it really appears that roy blunt retired
because he's scared of the trump faction
of the republican party
and ruining his legacy as a setting
united states senator so
sayonara roy blunt don't let the [ __ ]
door hit you where the good lord split
you buddy
so no republicans voted for
the american relief package in the
senate which
they we couldn't get the 15 hour minimum
wage in there which
means we need to get rid of the
filibuster sooner rather than later
which i think that there's going to be
movement on that in the next several
months
but then it goes over to the house and
they passed it today
um not without fanfare because the
republicans obviously they're gonna
do every single little procedural thing
so they can [ __ ] and moan about dr
seuss and and cancel culture and how
they're silenced as they stand in front
of a microphone and yell
into it yeah break your
silence that you in on the floor on
national tv
and talking to a microphone so the world
can hear you
what the [ __ ] marjorie taylor green uses
a procedure
so that way to try to stall this thing
which it didn't matter it's just
procedural it just
made it go on and on and on hell they
had a they had a vote-a-rama
in the senate on amendments to get it
over they're doing everything they can
to stall the payments
i don't understand that either they know
this is inevitable
the democrats had a strategy to get
these to get these stimulus checks and
get this coronavirus relief in the first
place
there was there was no there was no uh
situation
where the senate and the congress wasn't
going to send
a coronavirus bill to joe biden's desk
the question was was it going to be 1.9
trillion dollars like he wanted
that was the question
that was the question was it going to be
the amount that he wanted
was he gonna get that win and he did he
did get that win
he got the fourteen hundred dollars that
he promised every single american
he got the unemployment extended and not
only that he got this
child tax payment this ch child payment
and the way that works is any any child
that is between 6 and 17 and there's uh
you know it's on a ladder scale for your
income but as long as you qualify for
your income which i i believe is 75
000 a person and 150 000
is how the sliding scale works but
in 150 for a household but you're gonna
get between
six years old and 17 years old you're
gonna get three thousand dollars
over a 12-month period where they split
it up in payments
and then which is 250 a month and then
if it's
if the child is under six you're to get
you're going to get
you're going to get uh 3 600
so you're getting 300 hours a month
for those children and then there's a
cap on it of course you can't have you
know 15 children
receiving 15 checks there's a cap on how
much money you can receive each month
or during the year but it's a yearly
amount and then they pay it out over a
12-month period
which uh mitt romney had his own little
plan
and it uh it seemed to be a little more
generous than than
joe biden's in the democrats plan but it
was basically the same
you know six one way half dozen the
other people are gonna get money
and the extended unemployment uh he's
gonna get restaurant relief
we're gonna get a vaccine distribution
money to
dis distribute the vaccine to make sure
that these vaccines get in people's arms
so this bitching about how it's not
coronavirus relief is [ __ ] nonsense
just because just because it doesn't
have the word covet on it doesn't mean
they're not
that that money isn't going to help the
coveted crisis
that we've had the last [ __ ] 12
months
and you sound you sound like a tone deaf
[ __ ]
and haven't been paying attention to
what the [ __ ] going on if you say
that that kind of payment and that kind
of money and where that money's going
and how it's going to people
is it coronavirus relief
sound tone deaf as a [ __ ]
and who guessed it republicans sound
tone deaf
and not a one not one one
of those manga trump loving [ __ ] voted
for this thing today
in the house not a goddamn one of them
not [ __ ] one so no thanks to any
[ __ ] republicans
the checks that get put into americans
accounts over the next several weeks
probably by the end of the month
and then the child credits or the
unemployment benefits that you receive
are the vaccine that you get your arm
to get this [ __ ] over with not a god
damn one of them wanted
it not a [ __ ] one of them
they voted against that so when you get
your check
and you decide to either save it spend
it pay your [ __ ] back rent your
back mortgage your back bills have been
building up over the last year because
you couldn't [ __ ] work
or the amount of money that you received
from your work was lower because they
did keep the business alive whatever the
[ __ ] it was you had to change
jobs you had to change what the [ __ ] you
did
so when that money gets dumped in your
account you have that money
no thanks to any [ __ ] republicans not
a god damn one of them
and do you think joe biden's going to
print his name on the check
like trump did because trump stalled the
checks to print his name on him
because he wanted credit joe biden
doesn't give a [ __ ] he just wants you to
have the money
so you put it back in the economy so we
get this [ __ ] going
because it ain't about the [ __ ] show
it's just about turning the gears baby
turn into gears
so when he signs this thing on friday
and you start to receive your checks and
your accounts
do not do not think you can think
you can thank republicans and my my
advice to you
my advice to you america folks
is to next time you go to a town hall
and your representative is a republican
ask them why the [ __ ] they voted against
the american people
why the [ __ ] did you vote against the
american people and when the economy
starts
to roar this summer because my guess is
after this coronavirus package
uh rolls out we get the vaccine and the
people's arms
we can finally finally finally look at
what herd immunity means
and how that how how we can open up not
prematurely but how we can actually open
up
and maybe get away from from mask in a
lot of situations
if it's safe how that's gonna
get the economy going again and it's
gonna be roaring
hopefully by late summer early fall no
thanks to republicans
no thanks to them and i think we can i
think we can make them pay the price
electorally over this
because they're going to try to
gerrymander these [ __ ] districts
they're they're already on
this voter suppression uh a march
georgia arizona
all these states where they lost they're
really gonna work hard
work hard to make sure people don't vote
because that's why they lose people vote
they lose
and that's what we need to do folks we
have to vote and i think we need to
become
one issue voters and it needs to be
about this filibuster
it's where it needs to be i don't care
if your dog catcher county commissioner
mayor
how do you feel about the filibuster
what's your opinion on the filibuster
and senate
mr dog catcher candidate for dog catcher
well i believe the filibuster is a good
thing we can stall legislation
wrong answer next
mr county commissioner i think i think
filibuster is
is good thing wrong answer next
and especially these senate candidates
because there's going to be a
shitload a shitload of senate races here
and we are going to have the opportunity
in this country to actually show these
people electorally
what kind of price you're going to pay
if you do not vote on the side of the
american people
because not a one of them can i can i
repeat again
not one of them voted for it
and i'm probably gonna say this a
million times after this
not a [ __ ] one of them voted for this
thing
and as we see how this thing works and
and
what it does uh not only for the economy
but for the american people
the the actual approval rating of it
because right now
the approval rating is almost 70 41 a
pew poll this morning 41
of republicans support this thing of
course 41 percent of republicans
support 1400 going into their pockets of
course they do
of course they do
so as this rolls out and get you know it
gets more and more popular which it will
it will get more and more popular as we
see it work
we get to hold them accountable for not
voting for it
because they didn't vote for it
[ __ ] them
so we need to hold them accountable and
vote vote vote
vote vote vote it does not matter if
you're in a gerrymandered district
or if you think that your vote doesn't
count in your state because it's a red
state don't believe that [ __ ]
we need to stop that [ __ ] we need to
stop eating our own do
we need to stop this garbage
the moderates and the leftists oh we
want to fight
we're on the same goddamn team here the
same team
it's to beat the fascist that's the goal
that's the mission to beat the fascist
get the minority rule the minority
fascist rule out of our government
we need a majority rule it is not
radical
for people not to [ __ ] go bankrupt
over medical bills that's not a radical
thing that's not a radical idea
it's not it is not a radical idea
for someone to earn a living wage if
they work 40 hours a week that's not a
[ __ ] radical idea
and if you think it's a radical idea you
are a [ __ ] bonehead
it's not radical it's not
what's radical to say well based on
inflation it should be twenty four
dollars an hour
so we should double that and it should
be forty eight dollars an hour that's
our minimum wage forty eight dollars an
hour now there's radical
you wanna see radical there's radical
there you go there's your radical stance
if you want one maybe we should be more
radical
maybe we should maybe we should push for
the fight for 48
instead of the fight for 15.
maybe they get on maybe they get on the
right page and [ __ ] start talking
about 20
an hour minimum wage the son of a
[ __ ]
but i digress so the american
relief package is going to be signed and
i'm sure uh next week we'll be talking
more and more about
the american relief package as it rolls
out and we see how it plays out
over the coming weeks i i'm going to try
next week to have someone on
i've been trying to get an uh
epidemiologist but it's kind of
difficult when your podcast says [ __ ]
them
it's kind of difficult to get
a doctor to take the take seriously uh
when you're you're
when your podcast says [ __ ] um but you
know that's how it goes
so we're gonna try to get an
epidemiologist because i really want
someone to tell me the difference
between
the pfizer the moderna and the johnson
johnson
i've read everything on it um but i am
not an epidemiologist so i don't
understand all the
the the science terms and all that kind
of stuff i'm not a biologist either so
i don't quite understand all that so i'd
like to i like to talk to someone and
try to put it in simple terms and
and answer questions that americans
might have about these vaccines about
how they work
and why we should get one which one we
should get should we get the first one
offered should we wait for
the one that we want because we want a
particular one
um you know what what what is you know
what's the difference between them
uh you know what are the side effects
what side effects are we looking for
what side effects are you not looking
for
if you have tested positive should you
get one or
within 90 days i've heard that stuff you
know i've had it within 90 days i
shouldn't get one
so i want to i want to get someone on to
try to tell us all the facts about this
stuff
and really set some of it straight in
simple language
and really give us some uh some guidance
on
the vaccine and why we should get it
where we should get it which one we
should get or does it really [ __ ]
matter we should just get it
and that's that's my opinion on it the
stuff that i've read i think
we should just get the son of a [ __ ] it
doesn't matter which one
but again i wa i want someone who knows
a little more about this stuff
to really speak on this and give us
their expert opinion so hopefully
hopefully next week we can have someone
on and if there's any epidemiologists
out there on tick tock watching this
right now
right now hit me up hit me up i'll have
you on the show
either we'll do it live or we'll record
the interview and then you can come back
i appreciate you guys joining us again
this week this is the ninth episode can
you guys believe that we've been doing
this for nine weeks now
that's incredible i didn't even know if
this would last nine weeks but you
some [ __ ] just love listening to me
yapping to a microphone so we're gonna
keep doing it
we'll do 10 11 12 13 hell we'll do 400
of them if we have to
and i appreciate i really really do
appreciate you guys watching the show
um come support us on the merch store uh
all
or buy the [ __ ] hats you guys can see
the [ __ ] hats
we'll have some different hats as we go
along here but all that money goes
towards
the podcast and producing the podcast
and keeping it up and live
so you guys can listen to it on spotify
or youtube
also you guys have noticed that we've
been streaming on twitter so watch us
there just go to thetonymichaels.com you
can find all the links there
to the to the the youtube channel uh to
to the audio version uh where you can
download it on
on buzz sprout or or or spotify
you can find the latest episodes on
there the link straight to those videos
on youtube
you can go to the merch store and go to
the hat store to support us that way
and we really do surprise appreciate any
support i noticed a couple people
ordered some [ __ ] stickers
and also some coffee mugs so i do
appreciate that that
many many thanks to you guys um for
helping us out
and supporting the podcast and
supporting my content
and a lot of you since we got a few
minutes left a lot of you the last
couple days have been confused
by uh by a couple videos that i post on
tick tock i didn't say
[ __ ] um at the end and a lot of people
are like
what the hell is going on are you sick
are you sick you didn't say [ __ ] them
what's going on
oh no so i i i i decided that we do a
new series called
that is all that is all thank you
so what i'll do is i'll just take a
tweet that i have that i think is
relevant
and i just say it into the camera and
and then say that is all
thank you so you know um i like though
that you guys
went in the comments and did the [ __ ]
for me that's fantastic i really do
i really do appreciate i i i love that
you guys love that i
again i've said that for years it's like
my motto
[ __ ] up so
all right guys come back and see us next
week wednesdays
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern
every wednesday for about an hour i yap
into the microphone
you can find the links on the
tonymichaels.com you can go to the
youtube channel
subscribe you can also follow me on
twitter it's
there and i tweet all the time too so go
watch that and watch all my tick tocks
like
share you know all that kind of good
stuff and until next time until next
week
until next week [ __ ]